what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to adam
22 it's from the youtube channel
youtube channel no jumper it says adam
22 freaks out over brain dead women's
viral dating advice i'm just really
curious to see what this says
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell while you're at it leave a comment
let me know if you agree or you disagree
with the dating advice
oh wait um okay
so so there's a clip
on the uh [ __ ] what's it called fresh
and fit
podcast how's the fresher fit podcast
talking to them today we uh
we i tuned into this clip because you
know everybody's been telling us that we
gotta [ __ ] with them because they have
kind of a popping podcast coming out of
miami i believe
and um there's one clip in particular
it's like six minutes long
i don't know this is one of the only
clips i watched on their podcast but
it's
a couple of dudes [ __ ] 10 girls all
sitting at this table
i can't even imagine what they always
get the bimbos this podcast would be
like if we had 10 girls hitting here and
that's most of their content
right they have girls all the time and
they talk about it and like i said kevin
samuels he calls in all the time but
usually there's like six or seven women
at the table and they ask questions and
they go back and forth
so shout out to fresh and fit they be
kicking girls out all the [ __ ] time
really yes all the [ __ ] time that's
awesome yeah they kick girls
all the time because some of them get
real like kevin samuels
roasted one of the feminists on there
they had i think i saw that [ __ ] he
went on that that was like that
like a blonde yeah i think he was white
and blonde
yeah he [ __ ] destroyed her bro wow
kevin samuels broke her to [ __ ] check
that out because this girl i know
hit me up when i posted a clip of my
story of
one of his the viral clip i posted the
clip this girl i know hits me up she
goes
[ __ ] you for not tagging me in that clip
she's one of the girls in the team i'm
like
you seriously think that i was looking
at all the [ __ ] girls there enough to
like
did they even cross my mind that i might
know these people sit at the table
anyway
so there's this guy mr organic who uh
[ __ ] i recently
touched down with on instagram and he
has a
green beard which is something that i
might have to experiment with myself
i've never thought oh please
don't please don't worry about dyeing my
beard but there's a lot of gray in it
now at this point so
if i show up looking like i got [ __ ]
ecto cooler in my beard
you'll know what's going on anyway he's
sitting there mr organic we're talking
about fresh and fit right now buddy
do you know about that mother fresh and
fit podcast hell yeah okay so
in miami right so he's sitting there and
he's given a little bit of a
lecture for whatever reason about the
kind of woman
that a guy who apparently he's pretty
successful or at least he
seems to feel very successful the way
he's talking about himself
basically saying at a certain point as a
guy once you become successful or
whatever
that you want more from a woman than
what a basic ass dude wants from a woman
a basic ass dude might just want a hot
girl that he could take to the club once
you get to a certain level
all of a sudden you're looking at a hot
girl you can just take the club and
you're thinking like that's not a
million of you like he was basically
saying i've had money and
been in business for a long time so i'm
not impressed by the same [ __ ] that a
lot of guys are
this girl really feels like she knows
something and she starts responding to
him in the clip and telling him
men only successful men all they want
from a woman i think of the quote
is for her to bring inspiration to the
table
aka cooking wearing lingerie
providing him with sex etc
okay isn't that okay i don't
agree with that but isn't that unaware
what kevin samuel says
they want that they want someone to like
be fit feminine and friendly so like fit
would kind of go in with the lingerie
feminine kind of goes in with the
cooking and cleaning i mean i i don't
agree with that but i'm just
curious what you guys would say so let
me know in the comments
i i wish i had a heart monitor on when i
was watching this clip
because it made me so [ __ ] mad that
this [ __ ] has actually been misled her
whole entire life
but she's right all these guys want from
her
is to basically just be a sex object
because
you're a [ __ ] idiot and you have
nothing else to offer you look okay sure
but you have nothing going on between
your [ __ ] ears and she's just
telling this guy that that's how the
world is and he's sitting there telling
her
no when you get to this point in your
life you want somebody that you're going
to be able to build something with that
you're going to feel
inspired by that that's going to be yeah
she's the inspiration yeah but when she
says inspiration she means like she
literally wants to like sit on the couch
in lingerie and make you
i guess make more money trading most of
their content two guys
i'm curious do guys care all i'm not
even talking about like
money i'm talking about work ethic do
men care about that
because that actually sounded like what
the guy when i watched this original
clip
what he was saying like i like a girl
that like does things
but you guys would always say no because
that equates to money and men don't care
about money so let me know in the
comments she wants to be able to call
herself a muse on something
she is not most of their content is
women who think like that and they get
into it
back and forth it's like i would say the
younger version of women
that kevin samuels talks to insane yeah
that's that's what it's just like
i don't want enough of this [ __ ] to
really judge but it seems like they're
kind of doing
the thing that kevin samuels does where
you get these girls and you actually
find out what they're really thinking
but instead of getting like
you know kevin samuels demographic is
kind of like grown ass black women that
are past their prime and are
wondering why they came into a
relationship these guys seem like
they're really getting the the hoes from
the club
to just come sit on this podcast and
that's one thing that you never really
realize when you're in the club and
you're looking around you're seeing all
these hot girls
you might not realize that they're all
idiots
and yeah you could barely have a [ __ ]
fourth grade conversation with them
because that's what i
it's the same with a lot of guys i got
out of watching that clip it's like
these guys are giving voice
to the really good looking women that
have a [ __ ] iq of like 14.
and i've seen like i seen one that was
mind-blowing to me right
so they're talking to this girl and
she's like uh
yeah my guy that i was with right he
cheated on me so much he cheated on me
with five of my friends or something
like that [ __ ] god
and i'm like self-respect i'm like this
is a pretty girl too
and then basically they break down like
well was he was he paying for everything
like yeah okay he paid for her to go to
school and once she was done with school
she was like okay i don't have like need
you no more so it was like basically
you let him cheat on you with [ __ ] uh
with five of your friends and he was
putting you through school as soon as
you
graduated school you didn't want to do
that [ __ ]
is it bad he cheated on her like
more it was cool and then then on top of
that she was saying
yeah well i did porn for a year i don't
want a guy to like
oh that changes you know basically judge
her because she only did porn for a year
and she doesn't do it no more
and bro was like what the [ __ ] of course
a guy is going to judge you off of that
[ __ ] you know
people judge you for everything you do
you could have a conversation with
someone and they will judge you
based on that conversation like things
about your character
i'm pro-sex worker so i
don't think i should maybe be like
judging girls as harshly for that but
yeah obviously
when you're doing porn you also are just
accepting that there's like a cultural
reality of how a lot of guys are gonna
act about that how a lot of jobs are
gonna act about that you gotta be ready
for that but most of the guys that be
like it like from me having a lot of
homegirls and i talk to them about these
type of situations
most of the guys that these women seem
to encounter and they have these
problems
with are guys that have absolutely
nothing to bring to the table too it'll
be bum ass
hobo central hobo sexual ass [ __ ] that
just be [ __ ] the home girls to have
somewhere to stay
you feel me and like they'd be the most
controlling of like oh why are you
wearing this why you got this many guy
friends why you did it
and it's just at the end of the day it
comes down to like an insecurity that's
why when a lot of
guys will say it's all about money i've
seen girls
sent part over some broke guys so it is
not
a hundred percent about anything and i
feel like a lot of men
if we like i mean we all
at this table i could say are probably
in a different predicament than like
you know a guy that's like down bad and
just happens to like look up on the girl
that
has a lot of money and like popularity
or whatever
those are the guys that be the most
insecure that be
trying to control they [ __ ] because
they don't got it
and see this is what i want to offer
them this is what i was telling yazzie
earlier is that
women maine i'm sorry i wish you could
actually play like a recording of what
you were actually saying to yassie where
you're just like
you date blah blah blah you were just
like telling me your friends are ugly
like
no no i don't know i didn't say your
friends no
no she said that that she don't like but
she didn't like the way
kevin samuels um portray and how he
talks right
so i said okay if i i'd use the same
analogy with yuri
i said if yuri said hey i want a girl
like kim kardashian right now and i'm
not going to get with somebody
until i get that and if i told him hey
yuri you're out of your [ __ ] mind and
think you're going to get kim kardashian
i said is that being mean she's like no
so i said so what's the difference of
telling a woman
who looks not very attractive who
doesn't have a lot going for herself
that she's going to get a man that makes
seven figures that's in the top 10
of all men right and now i agree it
doesn't make no [ __ ] sense
and that's basically what i was trying
to tell her i'm like hey you got home
girls that
you call yourself that they're not
attractive right she's like yeah
and they said yeah so and they they have
thoughts that they're going to get a
[ __ ] like poo scheiste or something
like that like
she says yeah i have to tell them all
the time you won't get them exactly so
what's
the difference between a man telling you
that and somebody else tells you bad and
just horny as [ __ ]
and i also said that women equate guys
for the most part
based off what we can provide for them
hell yeah
and that's why if you think about it
like with yuri like
yuri is as a guy
yuri's looks are not holding him back if
yuri had
10 million dollars his looks immediately
are not
whatever but then meanwhile for like you
know if you're
if with a woman it's kind of it's not
really like that if like a woman has 10
million dollars and she looks like
rosie o'donnell oh
yeah but you're a [ __ ] like you're
really trying to live off a girl though
you're trying to use every part of the
buffalo
and that's and that's the thing that's
weird i never heard that analogy before
but he said f the [ __ ] out of her he did
not say mary that's you it's like i'm
not just using your [ __ ] i'm gonna use
your whip
i'm going to use your couch i'm going to
jerk off these tissues
i got my own couch yeah because use more
okay and let's say you're a great guy
right and let's
look look what society is did right you
have a song like
no scrubs tlc made i don't want no scrub
sitting on your your best friend's ride
right you can be a great guy going
through hard times and you're telling
you're telling women don't [ __ ] i don't
think that's fair
for women to say that i don't think
that's great with that guy and then you
got songs now
bro it'd be so many tweets and girls be
like yeah like like
[ __ ] want you to hold them down like
on their way up like i'll see you at the
top like yeah
like i won't even give you that chance
until you're already there but when it's
reversing we say
we don't want a woman that we have to
build up it's like oh you're the [ __ ]
devil
oh that's [ __ ] wrong oh that's that
and that's basically what i was telling
jazzy i'm like
the message the way that he does it may
not be the best way
because it comes off as mean but he's
telling
the truth and until people get a fix of
reality
they're going to be in [ __ ] up
situations and a lot of women
the the shocking thing to them and some
sometimes
i actually think what kevin samuel says
helps women more
than it helps men because it helps them
like that
in their league something about kevin
samuels's content is that
okay here is some content here's an
arena an environment
in which you're not going to get treated
like a victim and i think
so many women in american culture are
just not used to that because they're
completely used to
never being held accountable or being at
fault
and so to see a guy actually say like no
like you're not a victim and actually
you're going to be judged on your own
merits just like men at least while
we're on this show
is unbelievably shocking to them yeah
and the thing is
is like what boston oversaid he said you
don't have to call in
so if everything is going right in your
life and you're getting these men
that you so-called want why are you even
calling in to get advice from me anyway
when you already know what i'm about to
say
because you're not getting that and you
don't understand why
yeah i mean i think that most of the
women calling in
are kind of acknowledging that there's
something wrong they just also
don't want to they think it's the world
not that i'm held accountable for it and
they all think
that they're going to be the one to out
argue
kevin samuels even though he's pretty
much like based his entire life around
being able to win this argument
that's interesting dio um
i thought that that they definitely had
some good points of the women
in the fresh and fit podcast definitely
are not like um they definitely are kind
of crazy so i definitely see where
they're coming from but
let me know what you guys think let me
know in the comments do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next oh my
gosh
next time